very intriguing this whole xprize thing
it helped launch the what is now the
sort of spaceship one deal about ten
years ago but interesting that now
you're going kind of incremental with
some of the prizes to get a private
spacecraft of the moon we are we took a
look at what it would take to promote a
us as a spacefaring civilization there
are things you have to do to get out
there and one of the things you have to
do is make sure that space exploration
is viable it is not viable if it is
solely financed by the taxpayer all X
prizes have an element of private
enterprise about them you cannot use
government funds or principally cannot
use government funds to do the work and
so the google lunar xprize was launched
to lower the cost of planetary
exploration to interest young people in
science and technology subjects and
careers and to literally extend the
commercial sphere to the moon which at
this point stops at geosynchronous orbit
around Earth where telecom satellites
work let's talk about some of the
companies are working with SpaceX Google
Virgin Galactic where do they sort of
play in this because they're sort of
working against each other are they
competing for this as well as funding it
no Google is not a competitor they are
the sponsor the title sponsor of the
prize they're making it possible Virgin
Galactic is an outgrowth if you will of
our first x prize which was the ansari x
prize for suborbital spaceflight our
goal when we have an x prize is that
when it's one it's the beginning of an
effort not the end and we love so this
all the Virgin Galactic right which
looked like it was a one-off you will
pun intended but then it landed and now
it's gonna be a business right exactly
and we look to leave industries that
start nascent industries or industries
that have evolved as one of the results
of x prize that's what will make the
innovation sustainable without doing
that all you have is a stunt if you will
and we're looking for more than just
stunt demonstrations so imaging mobility
and landing systems talk to me about
what these prizes are today and maybe
more important what the innovations are
got it these are three important phases
of the lunar mission you have to get
there so you have to be able to land
softly you're getting there it's hard
Landing is hard getting there's probably
harder it's well and getting there is
mostly about capital and not so much
about technological innovation we have
the Rockets but it is part of the
Darwinian exercise to be able to
capitalize your adventure once you are
in the area of the moon you have to
safely get to the surface that's the
landing then you have to be able to get
from place to place on the surface
that's the mobility and then finally
that's the mobility part I thought of
that is Atlantic and then you've got the
imaging imaging I def is a requirement
which I appreciate is guessing the
high-def here in bloomberg TV right
exactly you want to be able to send back
video pictures and data in a way that
everyone can take in and as part of the
Google Lunar XPrize the competing teams
have to send back what we call a moon
cast of images of panoramic and other
views that prove they can do strong
imaging from the surface of the moon so
tell me about one of the innovations
that you're rewarding today so one of
them is for mobility most people think
of spacecraft that go to the surface of
another body and other planet as
something that rolls on wheels but it's
not the only way people have spacecraft
that hop from place to place they have
spacecraft that literally fly from one
spot to the next and not just roll on
wheels or trends so we look to award
teams that had brought their mobility
system along far enough to be recognized
and I do want to mention that an
important part of these milestone prizes
is we're looking to have the reward
match the risk curve if you wait till
the final prizes won until you're
actually on the moon then the reward
curve is a huge hockey stick that's all
at the end and we're looking to incent
these teams as they are on the journey
themselves most of these teams are still
looking to capitalize and these
milestone prizes are a way for these
teams to separate themselves from the
rest of the pack if you will it's really
intriguing not just from a business
standpoint but from a creativity
standpoint it seems like a really
challenge is the mind to go with neat
solutions Bob wise XPrize president
thank you very much for you could